what up space fam golden here from anime
upper and I'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest
developments in the one piece story we
got plenty to look forward to when it
comes to this epic chapter we got the
straw hat fights we got what happened to
Robin we got the trader Finally Revealed
plus we got the biggest craziest event
ever in the history of one piece so make
sure to stay tuned for this one if you
do enjoy seeing these one piece reviews
they want to keep them coming Channel
pirate king within and smash that like
button until you see fireworks if you
haven't made this video you joined the
Knockout by subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates and now
without further Ado let's jump into It
spoilers and all this chapter is called
Escape limit so right away we see sento
Maru saying Uncle kizaru which reminds
me of the very hype fact that we have an
admiral on the way soon Stussy is the
one talking to Santo Maru saying cp0's
mission was to eliminate vegapunk and
then wait for kizaru's arrival the
government actually extra prepared since
as they see this as an even more serious
matter than Ohara and it makes perfect
sense as tasa explains vegapunk took the
Forbidden research of O'Hara and even
continued it another reason is that
Egghead has combat strength that O'Hara
didn't not to mention the straw hats
being here sento Maru tells the
inhabitants of Egghead to learn from
history about what the Navy could do
here and that they don't have time to
hesitate they have to set sail and
escape the island before the Navy gets
here we then jump to Frankie Lilith and
usop usop and Lilith are statues since
they were turned to stone recently by a
snake while Frankie is still in the
process of stonification he says his
right side was off guard but his left
side can still move Frankie seems
desperate telling us snake he'll forgive
her if she undoes it although the
chances of that are definitely minimal
Pythagoras's head comes crying asking
for whose orders as snake is going off
of after all if they figure that out
they figure out the traitor but as snake
just goes to Stomp the head and then
there's an ex explosion it seems like
she's leaving so still we have no clue
how usop will be saved no positive
progress has been made with this group
so far we then finally jumped to Robin
and a lot of you were wondering what she
was up to she's here with tropper and
Atlas Robin is looking amazing in her
Vega Punk aesthetic it must be said and
she points out the explosions and
screams all around them must be because
of the seraphim being on a rampage Atlas
dose has its incomprehensible probably
because of the fact that without a
traitor this wouldn't be possible but
since there's a traitor it is it's
pointed out that if Nami screams someone
will show up to rescuer in a heartbeat
and as we saw last chapter they were
right and that person is none other than
Sanji we're told that teams that are
fighting are stuck Robin even says that
while they are busy fighting something
could happen to vegapunk so her Sherlock
skills are running behind a bit since it
did already happen he got kidnapped
already but she was smart enough to
consider it before the others finally
Atlas mentions the sealed off place and
they decide to to check it out it's
lucky that Robin and Atlas were together
here because as we saw last chapter Daft
Punk didn't tell anyone where he went so
we didn't know how they'd even know
where to find him when he went missing
we then jumped to the already mentioned
Nami and Sanji Nami is asking Edison to
stay with her while Brooke says he's off
to look for Vega punk in his oh so
useful ghost form love that ability we
then continue with Sanji being a badass
as many of you noticed last chapter his
eyebrow did change shape like before
which pretty much seems to be attached
to him activating his crazy German
Powers since all of his germa siblings
have the same shaped eyebrow above their
left eyes and while it's amazing how
strong Sanji is now he seemed to beat
Queen easily before and now he takes a
punch by S shark AKA Lil jimbei right to
the face Point Blank and everything and
he's fine his cigarette wasn't even
knocked out Sanji then asks with a smile
on his face if s shark understands what
the power of love means and I have a
feeling he's about to show us we know
we're about to see some Sanji epicness
here but then we jump to Zoro and Luffy
and although I want to see where the
Sanji fight is going and I think it'll
be epic still can't complain about
getting Luffy and Zoro time Zoro and
Luffy are having trouble because those
flames on the seraphim backs aren't
going away and while the Flames are on
they're practically invincible and
immune to attacks Luffy then points out
that the one with the Hawk's eyes
disappeared so it's interesting to see
something suddenly change in this 4 vs 2
battle they come to the conclusion that
it looks like he changed the order of
the killings he probably wants to deal
with the more Troublesome ones later and
wants to eliminate the weaklings first
an interesting twist and goes to show
how the seraphim can think on the spot
and recalculate in the moment Luchi
points out that in this case the
seraphim might think that if he gets
Luffy's friends it could shake Luffy and
Zorro and make them fight worse Zorro
says he will go after him but then Luffy
does something hilarious noticing the
similarity of kaku's nose Luffy tells
him hey usop go help Zoro since he gets
lost easily in Kaku doesn't like being
given orders by Luffy let alone being
called usop as he remembers later but
thus as he's told and tells Zoro to wait
up Luffy then uses Hawk Gatling against
S Bear telling the Flames to go away
balushi tells him to stop and think and
that they won't ever Beat It by just
throwing out attacks it's a great point
but at the same time they don't have
another plan so we'll see if Luchi has
come up with something useful definitely
as we saw with a snake and the bubble
gun sea stone or sea water could be very
useful here and stop these almost
Invincible machines but the question is
are they going to get their hands on
some or will they have to find some
other way to win stussy's lipstick would
definitely be useful right about now the
narrator then tells us something hype
this was the day before the famous
Egghead incident we are told which makes
us wonder what crazy stuff will happen
tomorrow but we're also told this story
began three months ago as we are being
told this by the narrator we do see a
crying Bonnie we then go to a flashback
to marijua three months ago a voice says
they'd like to discuss something with
the higher ups in the government the
voice says vegapunk is investigating the
contents of the Void Century of course
this must be the traitor after this cp5
was dispatched with an order to
investigate but no evidence was found
the ship though mysteriously disappeared
when it left Egghead cp7 and cp8
followed and similarly none returned
again the voice calls wanting to be
connected to the higher ups finally
after a conversation with this certain
someone and the five Elders it became
apparent that vegapunk betrayed the
world government the elders then decided
to assassinate vegapunk so it was all
because of this traitor otherwise things
would still be fine for vegapunk cp0
then received their mission and they set
sail the five Elders anticipated
retaliation from vegapunk and so one of
them set sail namely Saturn along with
Admiral kizuru as an escort crazy stuff
they also got requested reinforcements
from various branches of the Navy we're
told War became looming on the horizon
so it seems right now like the war will
explode into action tomorrow in a big
and famous way wow Oda is doing such a
good job of building anticipation and
hype right here it's just a question of
how long until we get to tomorrow
chapter wise we're then told that
unexpectedly the ship of emperor of the
sea Straw Hat Luffy showed up with such
an unforeseen development the government
steadily grew uneasy Saturn even looks
panicked saying not again so crazy to
think this was gonna be a war even
before Luffy's involvement we can only
imagine how big it's going to get now
and then we're told again the outcome of
the incident on the following day would
give the entire world an unthinkable
shock so the big question is to guess
what could happen that would lead to
this Unthinkable shock the death of one
of the five Elders perhaps by Luffy's
hands Luffy crushing the Marine forces
or something else what do you think will
happen let me know in the comments but
these are big words and obviously the
government just succeeding in beating
Luffy and the straw hats obviously
wouldn't cause an unthinkable shock to
the world so it's interesting to think
about what would another question since
we got a day until this incident is to
consider what other players may appear
to take part in this famous incident the
hype is real and right now we are
following a lot of different Pirates
doing a lot of different things and I
guess not just Pirates also
revolutionaries and Marines as well but
for now we jump to another hype topic
who is the traitor it's finally here
Stella asks was this your doing as that
Punk's body still lays on the ground we
don't see who he's talking to right away
but finally it's revealed the trader is
a satellite of vegapunk specifically and
perhaps not surprisingly its greed AKA
York of course it would be vegapunk that
could take down vegapunk ironic how
splitting himself up which could be seen
as a way to protect himself ended up
backfiring so badly York then explains
why she did it which is a big question
why would anyone do it York explains
that she wants to become a Celestial
Dragon Stella is shocked saying that
York has seen what's coming human beings
as Celestial dragons are and wonders why
she would want to be one it's almost
like he's totally ignoring the fact that
she's greed she just says though that he
sounds like Shaka AKA Daft Punk and then
says but guess what he's dead and then
she laughs she says it's really
confusing with so many vegapunks around
and that this world would be better off
with only one of them but of course York
wants to be the only one rather than the
original Stella being the only one left
the narrator says her desire has been
revealed and what a crazy chapter that
was it definitely makes sense that greed
would be the one to betrayed the others
and want to be the only one not having
to share the title of vegapunk Stella
looks horrified and I can't blame him in
a way he gave birth to this monster and
this makes perfect sense too since as
old established the seraphim won't stop
carrying out their order until someone
higher rank gives them a new one and the
Vega punks have no sway now because of
vegapunk already gave the original order
amazing chapter and like I said I can't
wait to see the next one and more
importantly to see what the famous
Egghead incident will look like will it
be a god Valley level incident as I hope
it will be while you wait you won't want
to miss my all rocks Pirates explained
video where I not only explain some of
the most famous pirates ever to exist
but also I go over the god Valley
incident in detail and it will get you
prepared for this famous incident where
once again something Unthinkable and
shocking will happen who knows maybe
GARP will even partake in this one like
he did in the other one link on screen
right down in the description to that
video and I'll see you there